manzil so this is cool this is one of my
favorite reasons to do the podcast is
that interesting people just reach out
and tell me about their business so
manzil is this so this guy sam reached
out he listens the podcast what's his
last name Sam and so he was like hey I
got this business you know would love
some help with it or just would love to
chat and so I said okay let's chat so I
get on the phone and I end up blown away
by what these guys are doing so they
teach me about something I've never
heard of and is now very finite very
very fascinating to me so what they do
is manzil does Islamic financing what's
that mean yeah we talked about not on
the podcast but we talked about it
offline cuz I was pretty interested in
it so Henry do you know what Islamic
financing is if you didn't know lead gen
I don't think you'll go this way so are
you Muslim I'm not I'm Hindu
well I'm neither but like my my family
is Hindu so I didn't know about this but
basically in the Muslim faith there's
actually a sort of the advice is against
traditional loans so interest which is
known as like RIBA I think in the in in
their faith is frowned upon in these so
a traditional mortgage where you go to
the bank you have your down payment you
take out a loan and you're paying
interest is actually not compliant with
with their with their faith in their law
and which is actually common and a lot
of other different religions is that
true yeah so i'm catholic christian and
was raised that way and there's
definitely rules regarding handling
money and interests and things like that
yeah and i think the fundamental basis
i'm gonna kind of butcher this so I
apologize but I'm just trying to explain
as best as I understand it so so
apparently your money you sort of fiat
currency which is just not pegged in
anything it's just a made-up concept the
the belief system is that money has no
value inherent value in itself and so
you should not be charged interest for
borrowing money which is this sort of
abstract
so they have loans or they have sort of
agreements which can work as long as
both sides are taking shared risk and
getting sort of shared shared upside
shared return in some way so there's
damn Islamic I believe so yeah and his
partner Mohammed is also so they were
explaining to me that hey there's this
big thing called examine financing and
there's these like challenger banks
since if you ever heard the word
challenger bank check this out it's
pretty pretty cool we know that banking
has been around forever these big Bank
brands that are you know in every
country there's there's big banks that
are worth billions of dollars and
recently over the last let's say five to
seven years there's these things called
challenger banks or neo banks they're
called and so in Brazil there's a bank
called new bank and you bank and brand
new bank is worth 10 billion dollars
it's one of those valuable startups in
Brazil in the UK there's challenger
banks oh my god I'm gonna forget that
but this challenger just means a new one
that's a start-up bank yeah and they're
they offer different things so what
these guys did was better digital access
so mobile apps quicker ability to get
sort of credit cards and debit cards
spun up and so there's you know there's
a couple of them that are huge now a few
different multi-billion dollar startups
done this well these guys have done is
they've done this for a faith-based bank
which is basically saying there's a set
of customers out there in this case
Muslims who are not being served well
why the generic banks and we can make a
bank that serves them better and the way
we're gonna do it is you want to take a
mortgage out you can either take a sort
of mortgage out to a traditional
mortgage which is not compliant or you
can take one out that's compliant with
your faith we've come up with a
mechanism that is blessed by sort of the
the village elders you know they're sort
of leaders in the community that says
yes this is you know I think sharni
allows what's called seeing its
compliant which our new law and then on
the other side this is this will this
works as a mortgage you can actually buy
your home and so these guys have this
have this concept and in other countries
this is apparently really big so in
Africa Indonesia places where the Muslim
population is the dominant population
they've already solved this problem but
in places like US Canada where it's just
a minority of the population is is
Muslim they don't have these banks yet
so I love this startup idea because how
are they doing
so how they're doing so there
they spent a lot of time making sure
that they can actually get it to be
compliant and actually get the financial
mechanism to work that took him a while
over a year maybe two years now they've
gotten that to work and they have
basically they have two sides of a
marketplace on one side they have people
who are investors because you know if
you're gonna issue mortgages their
average mortgages like $500,000 so it
takes a lot of capital to start this
business they don't want to be the one
they don't want to go raise a billion
dollars and then start issuing these
loans they want on one side to have
investors who will put in the capital to
fund these loans and on the other side
they want to have the borrow EES who are
trying to buy a home who can pull from
this pool of you know sort of halal
financing you know this this financing
that's compliant and so they have ten
million dollars committed on the on the
investor side 1.2 million in their bank
10 million total and then and they're
just every week they're trying to close
more of those nice I think which is a
small amount but this is like just
inbound interest this is not like
they've never really done anything yet
but 10 million will let you let you do
if you just do half a million dollar
loans that means they can do whatever 20
mortgage is right now and every mortgage
has a certain value so it's about worth
about I don't know 20 K a year to them
is that mortgage just in their fee that
they get on top of it and so and on the
other side they have all these
applicants I think you know about a
thousand applicants and these are what
they call super prime applicants because
these are people who are doctors lawyers
they have good jobs they they have the
money they have the means to afford
their homes they're just looking for a
solution that doesn't force them to
compromise their faith so I really like
this business little there's a working
model in the UK there's a working model
in in Africa there's working model into
the Indonesia there's nothing in Canada
where these guys are and there's nothing
really in the US where in America I
think there's look this up I think
there's like a couple million only to
two million I want to say roughly that's
pretty interesting I like that I think
that there's a bunch of weird rules
around banking I mean they're not weird
they should be there but and so starting
a starting a bank I think is it's so
nearly impossible
it's very difficult so what all the Neo
banks do all the charter banks do not in
real banks they're not real banks they
sit on top of BBVA are they
on top of these other banks and they're
just the the consumer facing layer but
the banking happens with their
underlying partner and it's sort of like
the lead gen model that you're talking
about they go to these banks say hey I
can get you a whole bunch more customers
I'm gonna spend all the money during the
marketing they'll be banking with you
but we own this sort of relationship
yeah and that's actually pretty common I
use this thing my debit card is simple
rightful I've heard of it yeah this is
my debit card it's pretty cool I like it
because the customer service I can just
text and they're like you see these like
young guys in Portland and they they're
easy to chat with and they answer 24
hours a day they were acquired for a
hundred million dollars and I was like
who's like a freaking Bank that's it
yeah and I did not a bank yeah and it
was what's called BBVA yeah that's who
they use BBVA Compass I think it's
exactly they're under there and there's
a few that are underneath all these now
the very first there's a now one of the
challenger banks got their very first
banking charter banking license which is
very rare if I forget their name but
they just announced a couple weeks or
last two weeks that sort of so now it's
very interesting now once that seal
broke because it was so hard to apply
for this yeah I think when they all want
it Robin Hood wants their license
Breck's wants their license it's just
very hard for them to get I think you
need 5 / 10 % in reserve yeah you need a
certain amount that's not it's just that
there's no incentive for the government
to give these out they're like you you
kind of highfalutin you know tech
startups do I really want to give this
to you
you've only been around for so long I
don't know if they I have the trust in
you so now the seals broke and the first
one got it we'll see what what that
means but what I like about these guys
is they're not a bank they're not taking
your deposits they're just doing loan
issuance so on one side they have the
reserve cap they're their investment
fund but they're using other people's
money OPM on one side yeah other
people's money to make the loans and
they're the broker and they take one to
two percent at the transaction fee and
people are willing to pay a premium to
have halal financing just like people
willing to pay a premium for halal meat
or for vegan they're kosher meat you
know whatever like right people are
willing to pay a premium for things that
are compliant with their faith I think
this could be big and you wants
interesting I think that they've had a
hard time raising money from traditional
VCS because this is understand hard to
understand yeah you have to like you
know most VCS are old white guys and you
know it's the sort of cliche and you
know I know they do look into it
I think that there's now there's the
natural challenges of any high
aspiration startup they have those they
have the problems that any any started
but that's really ambitious but then
they also have the problem of like first
they need to educate you about this
problem like you saw how I stumbled
through this explanation and I talked to
these guys for an hour you know and
that's where I am after an hour of
really trying to understand it but you
and you read this by FERC on your best
so I ran her yeah I ran it by him I
introduced them yesterday I said hey
FERC round understands this he's Muslim
he's an investor he's a technologist and
he's an entrepreneur if he doesn't like
this I don't like this see what did he
say and so he so he's like I've looked
into this he's like a lot of my friends
really wanted this I tried to look at
what options are available in the u.s.
they suck they're really super high
premiums is he practicing yeah like you
know to an extent yeah why I want to
know is do really like like he doesn't
pray five times a day but he doesn't eat
pork right so he's like culturally he
drinks but like his dad runs the mosque
in San Jose and you know it's like
culture who aren't incredibly devout are
into this if he had the option he would
prefer how Lal financing over not if it
was convenient and he's like the problem
with all the existing options they're
not convenient they're not easy to use
and they're very high premiums he's like
if these guys did it conveniently I
think this could be big so he's gonna
talk to him we'll see
like I'm not a practicing anymore are
you guys Catholic you're Catholic for
sure right do you eat meat on Friday I'm
let me to I went to an all-boys Catholic
high school I don't practice anymore but
that's another thing I don't eat meat
during Lent on Fridays or I try not to
so it's kind of it sounds like that's
what it's kind of like where it's like
people it's a spectrum it's a you prefer
it but not yeah you preferred especially
if it's convenient for you you you you
know the way Henry just said that a lot
of guilt they're like yeah I should but
I don't
so there's you know if you could make it
where people do what they want to do
without lifting a finger then they'll do
it you know that's great that's pretty
cool I like that I like that thing or I
like that angle of finding because I
don't know anything about Muslim culture
I don't know anything about Hindu
culture which is you where you're from
you I don't know you probably don't know
too much about Catholics yeah it's kind
of an interesting way to like look at
how other religions do things right
another thing that we should talk about
not today because I don't think we know
what we're talking about we definitely
don't yet is building things on
of banks I think that's super
interesting but what do you mean by that
so like what simple did and like what
the what's the name of this company
man's oh man spell it ma n zi l Manzel
okay kind of like what manzil did a
building a building a front end on top
of someone else's back end right which
is the bank I think that that's really
interesting
simple calm it's my card I didn't know
they did this at first this is kind of
what dropshipping is so where you build
the layer that says I'm gonna get the
customer to a landing page and they buy
yeah but it's just gonna place an order
with this other manufacturer and they'll
ship it directly to the super effective
I like that with banks because like
simple they did this I mean it's it's a
little different the card is all white
and expanding like looking yeah and
their app is really good and so it's
kind of interesting I think this is kind
of what Breck's is doing is totally
weird they're layered on top of
MasterCard I love these things I really
like that
[Music]
you